well Mr President it's good to have you
back I'm delighted you're able to make
the trip to be here and uh you know it's
an honor to be by your side
in the united defense against what is a
brutal brutal force awakens
300 days hard to believe 300 days of
going through this and putting those
ways to
brutal assault
on the Ukraine's right to exist as a
nation and
click on innocent Ukrainian people for
no reason other than
intimidating
and he's escalated as a soul on
civilians after
eating schools orphanages hospitals
landmarks it's just it's uh he's trying
to use winter as a weapon
and but the Ukrainian people continued
and Inspire the world I mean that
sincerely I just Inspire us but Inspire
the world with their courage and how
they have chose the resilience and
resolve for their future and the
American people have stood proudly with
them
Democrats and Republicans together with
our allies in Europe and Japan and other
places
to make sure you have the financial
humanitarian and security assistance
that if needed we're going to talk about
that today and uh we're going to
continue to strengthen Ukraine's ability
to defend itself particularly air
defense and that's why we're going to be
providing Ukraine with Patriot missile
battery
and training your forces to be able to
accurately use it
together and our partners we're also
going to continue to impose costs on the
Kremlin and we'll support Ukrainian
pursuing a just peace president
zielinski the United States stands with
the great people in Ukraine we stand
with you and a great leader and by the
way
we have a famous thing that occurs once
a year we pick the man of the year in
Time Magazine you are the men of the
year in this in the United States of
America
welcome we have a lot to talk about it
as far as yours thank you so much
brother and great honor for me
here
your journalists I thank you so much for
invitation I really wanted to come
further Mr President knows about it but
I couldn't do it because the situation
was so difficult and now if I'm calm I
came I mean that we control the
situation and because of support first
of all because of your support and I
really
I understand that we have very important
topics and we'll discuss them everything
so many challenges in Ukraine in Europe
in the world
from energy to
distribution battlefield but but I first
of all I really all my appreciations
from my heart from the heart of
ukrainians all Ukraine from our nation's
strong Nations all negotiations to you
first of all Mr President for your big
support
and Leadership of course Europe many
countries
helped us and are helping now because
the world's not over it's a bit about it
anyway but
that is your leadership thank you first
of all
thank you so much Mr President of course
thanks my partners and support thanks
Congress and and thanks from our just
Ordinary People to your ordinary
people
Americans I really appreciate
I think it's very difficult to to
understand what does it mean when we say
appreciate but
but you really have have to feel it and
thank you so much great honor to be here
and yesterday I was on the bus in
Buffalo that is the place on the east of
our country you know it all the details
we had so many phone calls and Sport
detail about it and I want to give you
something
one guy he's really real hero real
Captain
and he asked me
to pass his award and he asked me to
pass his work to President Biden
and you will understand
AC Captain forkheimer's battery
yes he's very brave and he said give it
to very brave president and I want to
give you that at the cross
for military
Merit that is one God loves it yes that
is from him and and I have the least he
wrote the list yes I didn't read Mr
President I can't read
is in Ukrainian language but here the
translation
and his name is I have his name yes yes
undeserved but much appreciated thank
you thank you thank you thank you he
said that's all many yes Brothers
this system saved so thank you very much
well we have a tradition here and I will
give it to him
my son who fought in Iraq
they have what they call a Command coin
you've seen those coins
I will make sure that he gets one of
those
again thank you thank you so much
appreciate it what a great honor thank
you